I will not be covering all of Donald Trump's
rallies from this weekend.
He did, I think, four on Friday, four, five
Saturday, five yesterday, more today.
The individual rallies really don't matter.
What matters is that these rallies are responsible
for at least 700 corona virus deaths based
on a new Stanford study, which I will get
to later in the program.
And the rallies are really at the end stage
of humiliating authoritarian desperation.
And that's where we will focus because this
is it, guys.
We either end this tomorrow or we get four
more years of it.
There are rumors that Trump might continue
doing rallies later in the week if the election
results are not yet completely counted.
If you can imagine.
But we are potentially getting to the end
of this.
But Donald Trump said yesterday at a rally
that he's looking at firing Anthony Foushee
after the election.
He essentially said, give me until after the
election to do it.
A fire foushee chant developed at Trump's
rally and up locka, Florida.
And Trump said, let me wait a little until
after the election.
Take a look.
Rounding that I say drives him crazy.
It's rounding the turn because all they want
to do your and is covered, covered, covered,
covered.
Go.
We'd like to talk about covered.
And then next year, here's what happens.
November 4th.
You won't hear too much about it.
You won't hear too much about.
Don't tell anybody, but let me wait till a
little bit after the election.
I appreciate that.
This is a sick country.
My friends, this is a disgusting and sick
country.
We are dealing with 30, 40 percent of it anyway,
from day one, dismissing and ignoring and
creating conspiracy theories about the virus.
Anything to defend and justify Trump's terrible
handling of the pandemic, making the top infectious
disease doctor enemy number one.
To the point where he and his family, his
daughters need full time security and now
demands for that doctor to be fired.
And the president, instead of saying, no,
no, no, this is a medical expert, 40 year
career of fighting AIDS and other infectious
disease.
Trump says, thanks for the advice.
I'm going to wait a little until after the
election to fire Foushee.
And to be totally honest.
You could put almost everything else Trump
has done, the hundreds of scandals, the tens
of thousands of law.
Put it all aside, this alone, when we have
cases exploding for a third time, 20 percent
of the deaths, despite having only four percent
of the population.
And Trump says fire Foushee, this alone would
be enough to say we must remove Donald Trump.
And by the way, even if he loses, he might
fire Foushee during the interim lame duck
period.
Joe Biden would have to rehire him, and I'm
sure that he would.
Ninety four million people have already voted.
We will know soon.
It's hours now, 36, 48, 72, maybe 96 hours.
And we will know whether this man gets rewarded
for another four years.
Imagine saying I'll fire Foushee after the
election and getting reelected.
That is what could happen.
Let's now talk a little bit more about what
happened over the weekend at these whacked
out rallies.
So Donald Trump did more than a dozen rallies
over the last few days.
He's going crazy, going 11 a.m. to 11 p.m.,
doing rallies in the dark, in the cold and
the heat in the wind, complaining about all
of the weather at every single one of these.
We've learned that these rallies are not without
negative effect.
We've seen old folks get hypothermic after
being left at the rallies with no busses to
take them back to their cars.
We've seen folks get heat stroke as they start
just spraying water onto crowds in the extreme
heat and sun.
Stanford study, which I will talk about, has
found that at least 700 people have died of
Corona virus thanks to Donald Trump's rallies.
And it is all about feeding his ego.
If you are delusional or whacked enough to
even go to one of these rallies during a pandemic,
you're voting for Trump.
He's not convincing anybody.
He's feeding his ego and just some of the
most insane things from the last couple of
days here.
I can't cover it all.
It wouldn't be healthy to expose you to all
of it.
But I'm going to play a few clips for you
from the different rallies.
Trump here actually saying out loud what his
philosophy has been, which is whatever Obama
did, I will do the opposite.
Frankly, we just said, what did Obama do?
And I heard and you know what I did?
I did the opposite.
I said, why did Obama do?
And then I did the opposite.
That don't work.
Now, there's one thing that's missing there,
which is everything Obama did, he will undo
unless it's something he wants credit for,
in which case Trump will just claim he did
it.
Obama protected preexisting conditions with
Obamacare.
Oh, I protected preexisting conditions.
Or I will.
What Obama did.
Veterans choice.
We did veterans choice.
Just say I did it.
That's the piece that was missing there.
Trump then continuing to glorify mob violence,
the surrounding of a Joe Biden bus and the
sideswiping of a staff vehicle.
Trump loves it.
They had the thing with these really, I would
say very good people.
They were riding along the highway and you
had sloppy Joes Bush.
So they escorted the bus and the radical left
said, oh, what a horrible thing that is to
escort the bus.
They don't tell you about it.
And Tifa that go around burning down your
cities, Democrat run only Democrat, they don't
talk about that, boppin people over the head,
killing people, extremely dangerous.
And we did an entire segment on that, so I
won't rehash it here.
Then Donald Trump now at a different rally.
Donald Trump says, you know, if Biden wins,
we're not going to have anything.
Biden's going to he's been saying Biden will
take away electricity and indoor heating and
cooling.
Now he has another list of things Joe Biden
will take away.
The Biden lockdown will mean no school, no
graduation, no weddings, no Thanksgiving or
Christmas.
No Easter, no Fourth of July.
No future for American, yes.
Other than that, he's doing quite a good job,
right?
The reality is all of those things have happened
under Trump due to his mishandling of coronavirus.
Remember, guys, in March when Trump said,
let's do two weeks, two weeks of washing hands
and then we're going to reopen on Easter?
It's going to be amazing.
It's Trump's mishandling that led to this.
It's a level of projection that in this this
close to the end of the campaign is just beyond
words.
It's an authoritarian nightmare as well.
Donald Trump during one of his Korona rallies
over the weekend, not accepting that there
will be a peaceful transition of power if
he loses.
And now they say, well, you respect the decision
of the voters and will that be a friendly
transition?
First of all, there's not going to be a transition
within.
But then you say then you say, well, let me
ask you four years ago.
Was there a friendly transition?
There was spying on my campaign before even
one.
And what was worse was they were spying on
my campaign.
After I won to overthrow the president of
the United States.
OK.
Which is called treason, which is called treason.
And let's see what the hell happened.
I don't know why it took so long, but it takes
a long time.
Trump still will not say there will be a transition.
We now know, thanks to the report from Axios
at the top of the show, that the Trump plan
is in any scenario other than a Biden blowout.
Donald Trump will step up to a podium and
declare victory tomorrow night.
And instead here he's saying, you know, the
real problems are the crimes committed by
Barack Obama, which, of course, he still can't
actually enumerate.
We've slid into authoritarianism.
It's happened slowly over four years.
If Trump had started with this four years
ago, it would have been wow.
But just like we've been warning about normalization,
it's a little bit.
A little bit.
And now Trump regularly calls for the imprisonment
of his political enemies of Barack Obama.
Joe Biden, Hillary.
And it makes news.
But it is not the unilateral outrage, the
unanimous outrage that it should be.
We've all become desensitized to it to some
degree.
Continuing, Donald Trump then fabricated a
meeting, which he then said was a phone call
with prime minister from Japan, Shinzo Abe.
The call never happened.
People just shrug.
It's not even remarkable that Trump is now
making up phone calls.
That didn't happen.
And you will eviscerate your auto industry.
It will be terrible.
We can't do it.
You know, we've worked very hard to bring
it back.
I've met with Prime Minister Obbie of Japan.
Great guy since retired.
He had a problem with health and.
But who.
Fantastic man.
And I said, no, Shinzo, you have to send plans
to Michigan.
You have to send plants to the United States.
And he said, no, no, no, I can do that.
That is a private decision.
I said, Ginzler, you're a powerful man.
I'm sure you can do it.
No, no, no.
I said you have to do it, Shinta, because
you're making too many cars, sending them
here.
We want to make the United States.
You have to do it.
This is what I can.
The next day, they announced there were five
companies moving to Michigan and.
Japan.
Japan is a great guy, that one.
Not only did that phone call never happened,
five companies that make cars didn't move
into Michigan either.
It is all made up.
Saturday night, Donald Trump was in Pennsylvania.
He again floated this idea of Obama and Biden
committed crimes.
The crowd chants, lock them up.
We still don't know what are the crimes?
Big tech.
You look at what's been happening lately,
right?
You look at the media where they refuse to
cover one of the biggest scandals.
No.
But the biggest scandal is we caught them
spying on our campaign.
Right.
We caught them trying to overthrow a duly
elected, commonly known as me, president of
the United States.
Let's see what happens.
Very dishonest, Fi.
You're right.
Well, not here right now.
There are a lot of people that call that treason,
OK?
That's treason.
And see what happens.
The people for law and order and due process.
Right, say lock people up who haven't even
been accused of a crime.
Trump still struggling with a lot of words.
Minneapolis continues to evade him.
And then Portland, we want to go into Portland
so badly, take out the anarchists who would
take us about 25 minutes.
You saw what happened in Minneapolis, you
know, after a week and a half.
They could have called.
They could have called a little quicker, like
not the only instance, you know, maybe just
avoid saying Minneapolis if you can't say
it one more.
And don't forget, they've done a terrible
job in Minnesota where they left Minneapolis
burned down.
And then here is Donald Trump saying ridiculously
that under Joe Biden I mentioned this, you
won't have heating in the winter.
You won't have air conditioning in the summer.
Biden has vowed to abolish the entire U.S.
oil industry.
No fracking, no mining, no natural gas, no
heating in the winter, no air conditioning
in the summer, no electricity during peak
hours.
Do his followers believe that?
I read an interesting piece over the weekend
catching up on my reading, as it were.
That suggests even Trump's followers don't
literally believe when Trump says things like
there will be no heating and cooling under
Joe Biden.
But they are okay with it because they just
write it off as this is how politics works.
Hyperbole and lies, which is problematic because
it normalizes it, which is the exact opposite
of what we need.
It should be ostracized, not normalized.
And then just to wrap up the insanity, at
an earlier daytime rally in Newtown, Pennsylvania.
Donald Trump, just after we set a record of
100000 Corona virus cases in a single 24 hour
period, Donald Trump repeats that.
We are rounding the turn and just doing great
on the virus.
We're ready.
We'll have that and we will have it.
But even if you didn't do so and I say drives
them crazy, we're rounding the time.
We're rounding that turn around, they.
And our economy went down less than any economy
anywhere in the world.
And it went up faster by far.
You know, they keep hearing about Europe,
Europe, Europe.
They're not doing nearly as well.
Seniors will be first in line for the vaccine
and the vaccine will be free because it's
not their fault.
It was China's fault.
China did this.
So we have to make sure we have to.
I'm not saying it's going to happen, but we
can make it happen.
We have to be at the end of these rallies.
Trump will do a few rallies today.
Trump may do a few rallies later this week
while the votes are still being counted.
We must make sure that by the end of this
week, these rallies are over forever.
We we don't have a choice.
It's it's a desperate, desperate situation.
We'll have more clips and coverage on our
Instagram page at David Pakman show for a
much needed break from the politics.
How about coffee?
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman for
my slo mo espresso shot from this morning.
The politics still matter.
But just for like a 15 second break, you can
find that on my Instagram The David Pakman
Show.